[Música]
[Aplausos]
para los seres humanos somos una palabra
muy obvia por un lado somos animales
nuestro cuerpo nuestro funciona el
funcionamiento del cuerpo entonces es
muy parecido al de muchas otras especies
pero por otro lado también somos muy
diferentes tenemos una capacidad de
desarrollar tecnología mucho mayor que
la de otras especies tenemos la
capacidad de usar símbolos en nuestro
lenguaje en adelante y sobre todo
tenemos la capacidad de alterar nuestro
entorno
hasta el punto de haber puesto ya en
peligro la sobrevivencia de muchas otras
especies hernandianos cuando yo vi por
primera vez a los monos araña en su
hábitat natural que se pierda
identificación de mi propia naturaleza
por la de ellas que con sus caras con
sus expresiones
las interacciones que tenían entre ellos
y ya conociéndolo es un poco mejor
después de haber empezado el estudio
sobre su comportamiento social
me di cuenta de que su sociedad
uno podía vencida alma se peleó con
berta y carlos como es amigo de verdad
entonces ahora ya no se lleva bien con
alma y al final de cuentas era como ver
una telenovela pero vos
y son estas similitudes entre lo que yo
sentía como mi propia naturaleza humana
y la de ellos las que me llevaron a
elegir estudiar su comportamiento social
para entender mi propia naturaleza
y todos ustedes conocen la teoría de la
evolución de darwin y la idea de que
nosotros descendemos el mundo
y valore decirles que esto es un mito o
al menos es una mala interpretación de
la teoría de mango
y darle dijo es que las especies se van
diferenciando unas de otras
tiempo y lo que vemos actualmente es el
resultado de millones de años de
evolución a partir de esta
diferenciación entre especies si uno
compara las especies que son sea que se
parecen mucho probablemente tuvieron un
ancestro común hace poco tiempo y si uno
compara dos especies están más formas
diferentes entre sí probablemente
en el árbol evolutivo nosotros estamos
en la rama de los primates que serían
aquellos indígenas de aquellas especies
que son más parecidas entre sí que con
otras por ejemplo con los demás
mamíferos dentro de los primates
estamos en la grama de los simios que
son los orangutanes los gorilas los
chimpancés y nosotros
somos primates sin cola
entonces hace 20 a 20 millones de años
nos separamos de otra rama de primates
son los módulos que son los que tienen y
entonces nosotros podemos pensar que un
ancestro común de todos los simios que
es justamente en aquel primer primate
que no tuvo bola y ese dio lugar con
ceros
dentro de los simios la especie más
parecida a nosotros son los chimpancés
de quien nos separamos tenemos
con ellos hace seis millones de años
para mí es impresionante saber que la
especie más parecida a los chimpancés no
son los gorilas y osos pero somos
nosotros o sea nosotros los chimpancés y
nosotros estamos en una rama en una
ramas de este árbol evolutivo
pero uno también puede comparar especies
y nuestras características de los obvias
como la cola como puede ser por ejemplo
del comportamiento social los monos de
araña pasan mucho tiempo jugando con los
araña juveniles y de lo que se plantea
este juego es de tratar de tirar a otros
una lucha de dos o tres individuos los
buenos del año a vive todo el tiempo
arriba de los árboles tienen una larga
cola prensil que les ayuda
sostenerse de las ramas y entonces lo
que hacen es tratar de mordiera al otro
a darle la cuerda para que se suelte y
se caiga no necesariamente al suelo sino
algún árbol más bajo y entonces el que
perdió la lucha rápidamente sube y para
de buscar la revancha con el otro que le
gano
y es muy divertido en este juego no se
acuerda de las luchas que tenía con sus
hermanos cuando era niño y son
justamente estas actividades las que
permiten que los individuos vayan
desarrollando en sus habilidades
sociales cuál es el impacto de mi
comportamiento sobre el comportamiento
del otro cómo fortalece en ciertos
vínculos sociales cuáles son los límites
qué cosa ya es demasiado agresiva todas
estas cosas las aprendemos tanto
nosotros como ellos a través del cuerpo
otra característica que compartimos con
otras especies de primates es que
tenemos grupos que no son estables lo
que formamos sus grupos
todo el tiempo se están juntando y
separando tal vez ustedes llegaron aquí
con un grupo de amigos que aquí
probablemente se juntaron con otro grupo
de amigos que llegaron por otro lado
después en la comida a través se junten
con otros en la noche también se junte
con su familia y así todo el tiempo
estamos cambiando nuestra composición de
los grupos que estábamos formando esta
es una imagen de algunos modelos que
nosotros usamos para estudiar está este
patrón de agrupación pero lo importante
aquí es que está lista esta forma de
agruparlos con grupos que se nos separan
y se junta lo compartimos con los
chimpancés también lo compartimos con
los monos araña y se cree también que
nuestros ancestros homínidos que también
tenían esa forma de organización
es decir una vez durante el día se
separaban algunos conseguía empresas u
alimentos otros se quedaban a cuidar a
los maduros y una noche se volvía a
repuntar
una consecuencia interesante de este
patrón de agrupación de esta forma de
organizarse es que da muchas
oportunidades para manipular la
información
yo puedo elegir informarle a los demás
que no estaban conmigo acerca de lo que
yo sé hoy voy a elegir engañarlos sobre
algo que yo sé pero ellos no saben y
entonces ocultar la información aquí
tenemos un macho alfa dominante de
pasión es el que está allá arriba y una
hembra que elige ir acicalar a otro
macho pero para eso otro más que no es
dominado para eso se van a esconder
atracción de manera que el macho
dominante el macho alfa no los vea
y lo interesante es pensar qué es lo que
están pensando esos dos individuos que
se esconden detrás de la tienda para
esconderse uno tiene que pensar y el
otro el manual
en este caso tiene una perspectiva
distinta de cliente o sea el de algo
distinto de lo que yo estoy viendo
porque yo me estoy viendo a sí mismo
pero sé que el atrás de la piedra no me
va a ver toda esta capacidad de ponerse
en los zapatos de nosotros a través de
imaginarse su propia mente se supone que
está detrás de habilidades típicamente
humanas como en esa vía de la conciencia
entonces uno puede aprender muchas cosas
a partir de estudiar a nuestras especies
más cercanas
ahora que soy yo cuando empecé el
estudio de los 20 años y me gustaba que
saliera de la selva y es bonito que
tengo en los brazos que es un mono que
llevó a alguien en el sitio escucha
nuestro
para ver si lo podíamos reintroducir no
se había repetido detenerlo de haberlo
comprado
y precisamente por lo que les acabo de
contar sobre el desarrollo de las
habilidades sociales esto es
prácticamente imposible durante los
primeros tres o cuatro años de vida los
duros del año pasan todo el tiempo con
su madre aprendiendo cómo moverse entre
los árboles qué cosas comer y sobre todo
los códigos sociales o sea el sistema de
comunicación el efecto de interacción
con los demás quienes tienen el grupo
todo esto un nuevo campo que ha crecido
en cautividad yo no lo puede aprender
entonces estaba prácticamente destinado
a vivir su vida útil
entonces si bien es cierto que tenemos
paralelos podemos encontrar uso de
herramientas en algunas especies y un
lenguaje hasta cierto punto simbólico la
realización social que puede llevar
habilidades identificables humanas como
la empatía también es cierto que
nosotros nuestra civilización ha poblado
la tierra y la ha transformado como
probablemente ninguna de la historia de
la tierra
también tenemos una capacidad de
reflexión sobre el efecto de nuestros
actos probablemente mucho mayor a las
otras especies y tenemos la ciencia la
ciencia nos permite indagar sobre
nuestros orígenes saber que somos
parientes cercanos de otras especies que
hace mucho tiempo no había especies como
las nuestras
todo esto lo conocemos
no es todo esto debería llevar a una
mayor responsabilidad sobre lo que no
son
presida vamos a hacer con el hábitat de
las especies en la tierra nuestros
países más cercanos
realmente va a ser un llamado concreto
de esta reflexión sobre su propia
naturaleza animal es un llamado completo
a evitar la compra de mascotas y
patologías
y yo quería
[Aplausos]
[Música]